uh happy wonderful tuesday everyone but
first just some somber news tonight uh a
good pal of the show paul sorvino passed
away yesterday
he was an amazing actor and one of our
first guests on this very show anyway
you might know him from the legendary
movie goodfellas one of the greats and
here's one of my favorite scenes
hey paulie i'll talk to you
i'm telling everybody you could be my
son could be anybody you don't mess
around with that guy but you understand
me
what garbage paulie don't make a jerk
out of me you understand i'm trying just
don't do it i won't don't do it okay
you're right you're right i won't i only
understand you're on the air because i
got you a job right right okay yeah you
see anybody messing with your show
you're gonna tell me is that right i
swear paulie
yes yes i swear
go do your show
thanks paulie
get in
there you're in a bad kid
needs another couple of smacks though
[Applause]
i will uh
i will never wash my face again lucky he
didn't slap me on the ass
[Laughter]
on to the news
it's fun to see what happens when
so-called compassionate libs get a taste
of their own no cost compassion you know
the kind they prescribe for other people
because they don't have to pay the price
but you do
take immigration where everything is
free for anyone who comes in because
it's in your state and not theirs sorry
texas you're screwed it's your fault for
bordering mexico
and inventing dr pepper
it's true
it must be how my parents felt when they
went away for the weekend and i had half
the chess club over to drink their booze
true there were only two people in the
club
so it was just me
now you get the idea
i drink alone
sorry
but forever
border states complained about the
burdens placed on their services with
the influx of illegal immigrants
they aren't complaining about the people
but the policies they know without an
actual process everything falls apart
it's like when edward scissorhands
entered that bouncy castle
as you know republicans are fans of laws
just like strict parents but democrats
are fans of stuff minus the means to get
them like strict parents children
so when border states complain the left
calls it xenophobic
oh you just don't like the brown folks
and they'll even say it to brown folks
the definition of racism has changed
again it's anyone who disagrees with the
democrat
and when the border patrol try to do
their job you get whip gate a smear the
president gladly embraced
so how do you get dems to understand
that you need a process
well you get them to experience what
you're going through too what's good for
the goose is good for the slander
er
let's see what happens when a democrat
far from a border state gets to play
border state for a year that's a nice
way of saying let's see how you a-holes
like it
i wonder if our system was inundated
our system is was inundated
with
of you know those who were seeking
shelter because of the callousness of
those other states that pushed them out
our schools are going to be impacted
our health care system is going to be
impacted
our infrastructure is going to be
impacted sounds like my dentist
everything's going to be impacted
which is what should happen when you
call yourself a sanctuary state
see the virtue signal just became real
it's the cost of lawlessness you know
sort of how a drug kingpin gets killed
by another drug kingpin those are the
rules
so i'm for having migrants come to new
york city and it has nothing to do with
having to replace my
masseuses r.i.p
marco clem and stew
you're never gonna find them
i want leaders to understand the cost
for their obsession with cheap labor but
i like immigrants especially compared to
what's homegrown here i mean have you
ever met a woke migrant
i haven't they think latin x are those
movies i made in tijuana in the 90s
and they're
that's right i met ricky martin
[Applause]
true there are burdens to the system
when lots of illegal immigrants show up
they put more stress on the
infrastructure than joy behar on a
toilet seat
but
they aren't even close to what some
americans have done to this country
illegals didn't upend the criminal
justice system they didn't create
critical race theory if they did they'd
be rich
they didn't destroy sports unlike megan
rappano you could argue they make sports
better
as for the two years of rioting i do not
remember seeing anybody running back
into a burning building because they
dropped a breakfast taco
oh racist would say
that was a shout out to dr jill
anyway there are horrible exceptions
they're drug dealers and gang members
and soccer fans
and we can debate crime statistics all
you want but it's hard when we don't
even call it crime anymore which is what
the woke did
not mexicans
and illegals they have incentives to
keep their nose clean
but be honest you would trade 100
wokesters for one hard-working dude
named julio who believes in right and
wrong keeps to himself has a strong
faith it isn't scared of a hard day's
work
if i could i'd take the trade i'll lose
a hundred liberal arts grads for one
great shortstop
now
now i'm not sugarcoating illegal
immigration that would be stupid to do
not to mention fattening and bad for
your teeth
i'm saying what's happening to mayor
adams right now is needed spread out the
resource burden and let's see how these
captains of compassion handle it because
in a real crisis words alone are not
enough you have to actually do something
hey buddy watch out
oh hey cat joe is that a fax machine
that is so awful please let me know if
there's anything i can do yeah you could
help me get this fax machine off my
chest of course okay i'm here if you
need to get anything off your chest okay
my heart goes out to you yeah well my
heart's getting crushed by this fax
machine
i'm starting a hashtag on twitter right
now okay justice for joe we're starting
a movement wow and ironically i'm unable
to move because of this fax machine i
hear you all right you're in my thoughts
well here's a thought can you push this
fax machine off of me oh i gotta go uh
i'm gonna be late for the rally
we've already got the flyers okay don't
worry i got you
hello xerox
yes i can hold
[Music]
so
this works with immigration how about
politicians who dismiss crime
they have private security gated homes
they never see what you see they're safe
and sound while you suffer and the worse
things get the more their gated homes
are worth and the cheaper the
landscaping labor
how do you make them see that besides
placing ads in modern wine snob magazine
that's not real
thugs commit crimes then are quickly
released and our governors don't do
squat
next time maybe we drive the perp to the
streets where the progressive idiots
live drop them off like a burning bag of
dog dung on pelosi's front steps ring
her doorbell and watch her face filled
with panic like she just found out her
plastic surgeon was run over by her
mexican maid
lastly it sucks seeing politicians
ignore violent crime while focusing on a
show trial because the crime hasn't
touched their lives they've got
taxpayer-funded security you know to
many of us january 6 seems more peaceful
than trying to get home after dark
think about all the criminals who got
away with brutal crimes while january 6
protesters are still in jail you know
maybe this whole time we should have
been getting violent street felons to
walk through an open door at the capitol
then they would have cared
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome tonight's guests
she's bright and sharp like a
glow-in-the-dark dart tag strategies vp
former director of press communications
for trump's re-election campaign aaron
parini
his pet peeves are communists and rust
retired marine corps bomb technician
johnny joey jones
that was nice
the difference between him and a deer in
the headlights is that people actually
have heard of deer
actor comedian and writer jamie lisa
and she's so thin her pajamas only have
one stripe boxes contributor cat tip
[Applause]
jamie obviously we talk about the fact
that you live in alaska one of the great
things there is nobody immigrates right
that's true except for seals and bears
that's true seals and polar bears and um
that's it it's been a good place
honestly yes to write all this stuff up
watching those videos is starting to
upset me all the violent videos i just
feel bad they're always beating up that
same guy with a blurry face
[Laughter]
that is true
it's just there's got to be a better way
to handle the border thing there just
has to be biden in his giving out
ids and like i just did hear that it's
actually faster to fly to tijuana
cross the border and get an id the line
is shorter than at the dmv yes
it's true
i love mexicans too but i'm a big fan uh
my writing partners from mexico city my
own brother-in-law is mexican they told
me something interesting they said you
can tell what mood someone from mexico
is in uh by the way they're holding
their gun if they have a gun um
sideways yes run
up in the air time to party
that's right
that's funny
i like it i was worried about where that
was
so was i
yes all right joey do you think this was
a good strategy i'm still unclear of
whether texas or florida sent anybody to
new york i think they came on their own
but i don't know
but i still think it's kind of this is
uh
it's wonderfully ironic i guess i guess
i don't understand because before greg
abbott did it the bond administration
did it i mean we've reported on it so it
was good when the federal government did
it it's bad when a state does it and
adams is not the communicator to get
this salient point across so it just
comes out like um like it's going to be
bad it's going to involve us losing
seats in our schools and all this but
you know what we're gonna want it to be
bad because that's the just thing to do
yeah on the ids on giving them ideas
this is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard and it's not because i'm for or
against giving them my ds i come from a
town that's 78 hispanic they're going to
take the id that says illegal immigrant
and throw it away right and they're
going to go down to a van by the river
and get as many green cards as they need
to circumvent taxes anything punitive
and to keep the benefits that dry up
every few months i've seen this happen
over and over again i've seen it happen
with my friends parents who were here
illegally and their and my friends were
not you change your id when the
situation needs you to you change your
identity you might go back to work in
the exact same manufacturing facility a
year later under a completely different
identity for tax purposes and everything
else this is where you know even
business owners are complicit in this
but there is a decades-old industry for
this type of fraud and their idea is not
going to change that this is how
killmeat has managed to be at fox first
that's it that's it he's been fighting
he's been fired almost i don't know half
a dozen times but he goes down to this
van i guess by the river by the river
and he gets another thing and he gets
another job he's been on like so many
fox and friends shows and some of the
they're just terrible but it's like the
you know
anyway i don't know what that means
aaron i'm just talking you're in dc you
have the same issue with uh your mayor
bowser still a funny name if you ask me
um is she dealing with this or not
no no one's dealing with especially not
democrats but all of a sudden they're
surprised now that oh play stupid games
win stupid prizes you want to have an
open border and they're going to do
these late night flights to joey's point
about they are moving illegal immigrants
further into the interior of the united
states we hear about it in pennsylvania
and other places and then they're all of
a sudden shocked that there are illegal
immigrants in their communities and it's
a strain on their system i i don't know
what they expected to happen but all of
a sudden now they need to face the
reality that open border policies will
lead to more people coming into the
country it seems common sense but they
don't seem to have that yeah and they
won't and they and they're totally
against any kind of process that would
actually streamline this because i i
mean i believe in the i believe that
america is made up of risk takers cat
you know about taking risks yes yes
i happen to like risk takers people that
come here to defy all odds like my
parents did when they moved from
san jose california to san mateo
california
it went on the 101 it was 30 40 minutes
wow probably some mid to light traffic
but they did it anyway u-haul
wow that's like a laura ingalls wilder
situation it really was it really was
they moved from the trailer park to a
trailer parked
a little bit more land a little bit more
room to grow that was moving on up you
know
what's your take on all this yeah i
think that look i think that anybody who
wants to come contribute to our economy
that's non-violent should be encouraged
and welcome to do so yes and so many
times when we talk about the problems
with immigration it's not really the
problems with immigration or with
immigrants at all it's the problem with
our welfare state so it's not so much
that there is strain on the system it's
that the system is a strain on everyone
and all of us and i think we need to
start looking at it that way that's a
great point thanks there you go
all right yes you can applaud
i'll give you that
all right that's enough
all right up next do certain names for
hounds mean they'll spend more time at
the pound hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else